Bienvenidos a economía de fin de semana
en francés 24 hoy hablaremos de los
retos económicos que tiene el mundo en
particular América Latina en medio de la
coyuntura que se está viviendo una
inflación al alza a las tasas de interés
en el mismo sentido para combatirla el
cambio climático que ejerce presión
sobre las autoridades para que tomen
medidas urgentes también los temores por
el colapso de instituciones financieras
en Estados Unidos que avivaron el
fantasma de la recesión ocupan entre
muchos otros la agenda mundial invitamos
para esta edición entonces a Alfonso
García Mora lcl vicepresidente regional
para Europa América Latina y el Caribe
de la corporación financiera
internacional Este es el prestamista de
privado para el Banco Mundial Muchas
gracias por estar acá gracias a ustedes
le pregunto bueno los sectores público y
privado tuvieron esta semana los ojos
puestos sobre el colapso de al menos dos
bancos en Estados Unidos eso ha puesto
sobre las a muchas empresas tecnológicas
que tienen sus depósitos en pequeños
bancos qué tan saludable es el sector
privado en América Latina y esas
empresas tecnológicas esas startups que
están de moda están por estos días bueno
buena pregunta y yo creo que estamos
ante una situación compleja la coyuntura
financiera es compleja por lo que
sucedió Hace unos días en Estados Unidos
pero yo creo que estaba muy vinculado
ese proceso o lo que sucedió a una
tipología de entidades financieras
concreta que tenían un modelo de negocio
muy de concreto muy definido que
probablemente poco tiene que ver con la
el depositante es decir con las
compañías tecnológicas que tenían sus
depósitos
de estas en estas entidades financieras
y más tenía que ver con el modelo de
negocio de los propios bancos no que era
un modelo de negocio que en cierta
medida asumía en riesgos que no estaban
bien medidos en el momento en el que eso
se puso en marcha no Entonces yo no creo
que esto vaya a tener un impacto sobre
las empresas tecnológicas directamente
si desde luego puede tenerlo en del
sector financiero No claro y
precisamente este sector tecnológico
Cómo se está comportando en la región
ustedes son la corporación financiera
internacional juega un papel fundamental
porque ayuda al sector privado
precisamente a financiar grandes
proyectos entonces en qué se están
enfocando hoy como el papel Cuál es el
papel del sector tecnológico Por ejemplo
yo creo que es un sector clave es un
sector clave porque sabemos sabíamos que
era un sector clave desde hace muchos
años sin duda Pero yo creo que con la
pandemia nos dimos cuenta de que
aquellas economías que estaban más
digitalizadas aquellas economías que
tenían más soluciones tecnológicas para
el acceso a servicios o productos fueron
los países que mejor lidiaron con los
impactos de la pandemia no yo creo que
como consecuencia de eso ha habido un
incremento significativo de la atención
pública de las políticas públicas para
potenciar la digitalización de las
economías Y expandir esa digitalización
a todos los sectores no y ahí es donde
las empresas tecnológicas obviamente
están jugando un papel fundamental
porque América Latina no hay que olvidar
está todavía lejos de donde debería
estar en términos de digitalización hay
un porcentaje elevado de la población
que todavía no tiene acceso a banda
ancha que no tiene acceso a medios
digitales Y eso obviamente limita su
capacidad para acceder a educación a
servicios financieros a sanidad incluso
a compras minoristas no del día a día
claro Alfonso y justamente usted hablaba
de la pandemia y la pandemia cambió toda
la manera de ver inclusive de empleados
y empleadores esto cambió todo el empleo
y la forma como la gente está trabajando
se impulsó mucho el teletrabajo pero
también usted menciona que hay mucho por
hacer todavía se ha podido recuperar
todo ese empleo que se perdió en la
pandemia Y cómo está cambiando ese
panorama yo creo que en términos de
empleo sí se recuperó en gran parte sino
todo el empleo depende de unos países
han podido comportar de forma distinta
pero en media yo diría
y pero yo creo que lo más importante y
lo más interesante del impacto de la
pandemia lo primero haber visto la
resiliencia de la sociedad no decir si
alguien nos hubiera preguntado hace
cinco años usted me hubiera preguntado a
mí en un plato como este hace cinco años
qué ocurriría si esto esto pasa jamás
hubiéramos pensado que los países y la
sociedad hubiera respondido como
respondió no pero yo creo que junto a
eso que es un buena una Buena lección
aprendida de los resiliente que es la
sociedad y los sistemas productivos lo
segundo es lecciones positivas de la
pandemia no decir aprendimos a trabajar
de forma distinta a ser productivos de
forma distinta a interrelacionarlos de
forma distinta y yo creo que esas son
lecciones que no fueron un One off que
no fueron cosa de un día y ahora
volvemos a lo anterior sino que
realmente lo que hay que hacer es
internalizar esas aprendizajes en la
forma en la que hoy en día operamos
implica absolutamente todos los sectores
de la economía No claro y en la pandemia
y después la guerra en Ucrania también
nos trajeron otra cosa que fue
altísima y todos los bancos centrales de
la región
elevando las tasas de interés para
combatir esa inflación eso también nos
trae un nuevo panorama para el sector
privado cómo está en qué papel está
jugando las tasas de interés altísimas
se acabaron los intereses bajos Qué
papel están jugando esas tasas ahora en
el sector privado
es clave la pregunta que me está
haciendo porque obviamente yo creo que
es el gran elemento
de preocupación en la reactivaciones de
las economías no en mis conversaciones
con los ministros o con Los Altos
ejecutivos de empresas el coste de
financiación es un problema porque ha
aumentado de forma muy significativa ya
no solo por el nivel que tenemos sino
porque veníamos de más de 10 años con
las tasas de interés en tipos bajísimos
es decir estábamos como si dijéramos mal
acostumbrados no podíamos incluso haber
internalizado que esa era la situación
normal y no lo era Y eso lo que generó
fue un endeudamiento en algunos países
en algunos sectores en algunas empresas
excesivo
una subida a las tasas de interés esos
endeudamientos excesivos obviamente
tienen que pagar intereses Y entonces
genera digamos más tensión en algunas
economías y en algunos y en algunos
sectores y aquellos que quieren acometer
nuevas obras de inversión O nuevos
proyectos de inversión pues obviamente
lo tienen que hacer con unos costes
financieros más altos significa eso que
es todo lo que va a generar es una mayor
una recesión económica o una mayor o una
menor inversión privada Mire yo creo que
lo que está generando es dos cosas Una
una mayor necesidad de sector privado
los
digamos los políticas presupuestarias
los balances públicos están en niveles
muy altos de déficit es muy difícil que
los gobiernos puedan llevar a cabo gran
parte de los proyectos de inversión que
requieren las economías y por lo tanto
necesitan que el sector privado entre y
que el sector privado ayude a
cofinanciar gran parte de esos proyectos
y yo creo que eso es lo que está pasando
no decir lo que lo que estamos viendo
nosotros desde la corporación financiera
internacional es como el privado está
realmente viendo esto como una
oportunidad para incrementar sus
inversiones y especialmente en sectores
que son clave para el desarrollo de las
economías no y cuáles son precisamente
su desarrollo de las economías acá en en
América Latina que están viendo ustedes
que se está moviendo más y hacia donde
la gente debería apuntar miren nosotros
tenemos tres grandes objetivos en
América Latina no Uno la inclusión como
una entidad en una institución
financiera de desarrollo obviamente es
clave y América Latina hay que recordar
es la región más desigual del mundo es
más desigual que África es más desigual
que es el sudeste asiático o que
midelista por lo tanto hay una hay una
agenda de inclusión que es fundamental
seguir trabajando en ella y la gente de
inclusión está muy vinculada a lo que
comentábamos anteriormente la
digitalización que puede apoyar esa
mayor inclusión y la inclusión es
financiera es Social es de colectivos
que están más excluidos es de género es
realmente generar una sociedad más
cohesionada no inclusiva
segundo aspecto Y eso genera muchas
necesidades de inversión sin duda alguna
en digitalización pero de nuevo insisto
en todos aquellos servicios que pueden
beneficiarse de la tecnología y de la
digitalización por ejemplo elige sanidad
online no eso está revolucionando porque
ahora tenemos capacidad de llegar con
soluciones sanitarias a zonas Rurales
que no tenían la capacidad de acceder o
educación Exactamente igual no segundo
ámbito el clima la sostenibilidad
América Latina no es para nada una de
las regiones más emisoras de en gases de
efecto invernadero no es una de las
causantes digamos del es una de las
mayores causantes del del change no del
cambio climático los efectos del cambio
climático Pero sí va a ser una de las
regiones que más se va a ver impactada
por los efectos negativos del cambio
climático y por lo tanto es necesario
invertir en adaptación es necesario
adaptar los sistemas productivos adaptar
la agricultura adaptar el consumo de
agua de las ciudades de los ciudadanos
adaptar las la forma en la que
construimos las que edificamos porque lo
que viene serio y la ONU lo lleva
diciendo desde hace muchos años señores
en los efectos del cambio climático ya
están aquí los estamos viendo todos los
años tenemos catástrofes climáticas y lo
peor está por venir por lo tanto es muy
necesario hacer esas inversiones En
clima y el tercer ámbito es la
productividad América Latina sigue
teniendo un problema de crecimiento
empresarial y ahí es donde el ifc la
corporación financiera internacional
también sigue apoyando al sector
productivo para conseguir que las
empresas continúen incrementando su
crecimiento y en cierta medida la
productividad de competitividad de sus
países claro quiero detenerme sobre un
punto que usted tocaba muy importante y
es el cambio climático y todas esas
inversiones que se requieren para
transitar hacia energías más verdes
América Latina tiene una particularidad
Y es que hay varios países que dependen
exclusivamente o dependen en gran medida
sus economías del desarrollo de por
ejemplo de hidrocarburos Colombia es un
país con muchos hidrocarburos México lo
es Brasil lo es como hacer también para
equilibrar esa balanza entre dejar de
consumir combustibles fósiles en de aquí
a un futuro cercano pero al mismo tiempo
Buscar otras soluciones para la economía
Yo creo que esa es una pregunta clave y
es obviamente un objetivo primordial de
la corporación financiera apoyar en la
lo que denominamos la transición
energética no decir esto no es algo que
cambie de la noche a la mañana no
podemos asumir que cambiamos nuestra
forma de nuestros impulsos energéticos
de la noche a la mañana pero sí existe
un camino tiene que existir un camino
tiene que existir una agenda de poco a
poco irremplazando
las energías más contaminantes por
aquellas renovables no y América Latina
tiene una una oportunidad espectacular
porque la biodiversidad y la capacidad
de generación eléctrica mediante Fuentes
renovables que existen América Latina no
existen muchos otros lugares del mundo
no y yo creo que es un proceso que
tenemos que seguir apoyando y que
tenemos que impulsar de forma en digamos
incluso ambiciosa no puedo darle un
ejemplo el hidrógeno verde no es una
nueva tecnología de energética que puede
revolucionar en gran medida el consumo
energético del mundo no América Latina
ya está el ifc la corporación está
trabajando en muchos países en América
Latina de momento en proyectos piloto
para hacer que esta energía verde pueda
sustituir hidrógeno verde pueda
sustituir en algún día en algún momento
de forma mucho más manifiesta otras
fuentes más contaminantes no Alfonso
Muchas gracias por estar en 24 muchas
gracias a ustedes a ustedes también
gracias por su sintonía los invitamos a
que vean este y otros programas en
France 24.com
[Música]